[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: As developers,
there's nothing we
like more than an amazing
activity that delights
and entertains our users.
But sadly, initializing all
the subsystems, resources,
and layouts to provide that
experience takes a bit of time
and memory, meaning
the users are
going to have to wait for
their transcendent experience.
My name is Colt McAnlis, and
one of the most important things
that you can do for the
health and performance
perception of your application
is optimizing the performance
of loading your activities.
Remember, when the
user launches your app,
they'll be shown a start window
while your app is loading
and getting ready to display.
Now, most of the time, if your
user is spending too much time
staring at the
screen, the problem
is most likely to be in the
creation of your main activity.
I mean, a bunch of
stuff happens here.
You're setting the theme data,
inflating view hierarchy,
loading bitmaps,
deserializing network fetches,
writing user
preferences-- you know,
all the stuff you need
to display your activity.
But if you're not careful,
each of these little operations
can fall into their own
performance pitfalls-- things
like multiple garbage
collection events
or waiting to inflate views or
blocking on network requests--
all things which can
delay the time it
takes for the first pixel
to be shown to the user.
So if you'd like to streamline
your activity loading to give
users the best
experience possible,
here's what you need to do.
First, figure out
if you actually
have a problem, which you can
do with the method tracing tool.
This will give you a
snapshot of your call stack
and let you visually
see what functions
are taking longer than others.
If the onCreate function
of your activity
is taking longer than
16 to 30 milliseconds,
then it's worth exploring
more to see what
might be causing the delay.
And this can be done by
inserting trace commands
at various parts of your code.
When you do this, the
timing between the
begin section and end sections
will be logged and then
displayed in your
Systrace captures
so that you can see more
information about where
your time is going.
Now, if you've found that your
load time is taking too long,
hopefully you've been
able to narrow it
down using the
inline tracing code.
If not, here's a couple
of common problems
and how to address them.
Firstly, the most common problem
we see with slow activity loads
has to be the time it takes
to inflate a view hierarchy.
See, the larger your
hierarchy, the more time
it's taken to inflate
it, and the more bitmaps
or resources it requires to
load also adds to its load time.
As such, anything you can
do to flatten the hierarchy,
reduce complexity, or stub out
portions that aren't visible
right now will help to
reduce the time spent
doing this work at the
creation time of your activity.
Secondly, try to
structure your code
to rely on lazy loading
and async processing
as much as possible.
Commonly, the onCreate
method of your activity
becomes a junk
drawer for all sorts
of different
initialization routines.
Some of those things do
need to happen right now.
Others can be
delayed until later.
This includes things like
doing initial minimal loading
of your hierarchy, loading
all of your initial images
in an async fashion, and
waiting to initialize
heavy [INAUDIBLE] systems until
they are absolutely needed.
Really, the lazier you
can make the creation
and loading of your activity,
the better your performance
will be.
But that doesn't
mean you need to be
lazy about the rest of your
application performance,
which is why you should check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns videos.
And don't forget to join
our Google+ community too.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember
#perfmatters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]